[Music]
thank you
John Karen said on the telephone in a
very excited voice he had just read
Mendel's papers
and you know they are the most beautiful
experiments in biology
and I gasped
and I said John John you can't say that
you said
the message install experiment was the
most beautiful experiment in biology
oh did I well I was wrong
Watson and didn't make a discovery they
proposed a model
there are those who believe this model
must be true because it was so beautiful
and there were those who believed it
must be wrong because biology is
complicated and this model is too simple
to be right
would you say exactly yes but there was
no experimental proof of it they had a
model which made a distinct prediction
about how DNA replicates and it needed
to be tested and it's fun to test
the hypothesis
we agreed that we were going to work to
get together to figure out whether or
not it was right
when Frank and I showed
semi-conservative replication it wasn't
just a model it was something real like
that
after our experiment that was now widely
accepted that their model Watson Creek
model is right
so it became the building block
you might say for all of biology yeah
from very early childhood I mean
practically infancy I love science I
loved to put wires together to make
little radios
which I could put under my pillows so my
parents wouldn't know that I was
listening to them all night long and
then I was very interested to know what
makes life work
and there had been I think
in the house maybe even in my bedroom
that
painting by Michelangelo
you've gone up high and Adam Bill and
they're touching fingers
I don't know if
there is a spark I don't think there's a
spark in the picture but I'm not sure
but to me that meant that life is
somehow electrical
that God is providing life through a
spark
and for some reason that made me
interested in electrochemistry
unlike Matthew I had no particularly
strong interest in science
as a as a youth what was understood that
when I graduated from high school I
would apply to the Naval Academy
that's what my mother had in mind
because she thought I would look good in
dress whites
but then of course World War II broke
out so that plan changed fast and she
decided I should just go to college I
think I was just too young to understand
the courses in Humanities I hadn't had
enough life experience to get a grip on
the questions they were even thinking
about
science on the other hand was concrete
children can can grasp science
and Among The Sciences biology was the
most appealing there the fun was that
you could figure out puzzles that is
there was a rational concrete
quantitative explanation for what you
saw you could reason backwards as to
what must be going on
and that intrigued me enough to know
that genetics was something perhaps I
could do
they had the great good luck to become
lettuce polling's last graduate student
his daughter was having a party at the
swimming pool and I'm in the water and
Pauline comes out the world's greatest
chemist and he's I'm all naked and
practically a bathing suit and he's all
dressed up with a jacket and a vest and
a necktie and he looked down at me well
Matt what are you going to do next year
and I'd already signed up to go to the
the committee on mathematical biophysics
and light has looked down at me and he
said but Matt that's a lot of baloney
come be my graduate student and so if I
hadn't taken his course on the nature of
the chemical bond I would have had a
very different life I wouldn't have met
Frank I wouldn't uh I wouldn't be
sitting here that's for sure at the end
of my PhD exam as we were walking out of
the little exam room Linus Pauling
turned to me and he said Matt you're
very lucky you're entering this field
just at the right moment yeah at the
very beginning yeah
foreign
the first year of my being a graduate
student at Caltech I wanted to get into
biology I was a chemist and I thought
the way to do that would be to study
molecular structure the only person who
was looking at biology from that point
of view other than Linus Pauling himself
was Max dilbrick he had a fearsome
refutation nevertheless I got up my
courage went to see him he's not a
fearsome creature at all really and the
first thing he said was what do you
think about these two papers from Watson
and Crick I said I'd never heard of them
I was still in the Dark Ages
and he yelled at me he said get out and
don't come back till you've read them
[Music]
there were two separate ideas that came
together crick's idea about how the base
pairs linked on to the chains and Jim's
idea about how the base pairs were
structured
so there are four different building
blocks in DNA and name thymine guanine
and cytosine the surfaces of the G and
the Sea are complementary to each other
and at the A and T are complementary to
each other
so that they can fit together the way
fingers would fit into a glove
and importantly when they put G opposite
C
the distance of the outside was exactly
the same as if they put a opposite t
no other combination would give such a
regular structure it was a gorgeous
insight
and then from that they made a
hypothesis about how DNA is replicated
it involved the two chains coming apart
and each one acting as a template for
the synthesis of a new chain on its
surface
when it's all done here we have the two
old chains each one now associated with
a brand new chain
Watson and Crick proposed was enormous
stimulus to experimentation it was
irresistibly beautiful irresistibly
beautiful
Jim Watson was at Caltech the year after
he and Francis published their papers
and so I got a chance to talk a lot with
Jim then in that coming summer he was
going to go and teach the physiology
course at Woods Hole
I was a graduate student at Rochester at
the time my chairman of the department
who was also on my committee said I had
to take a foot course in physiology and
I said the physiologist teacher here is
a jerk I'll be damned if I'll take his
course well send him to Woods Hole to
take the physiology course there and by
Serendipity Jim Watson happened to be
there with some kid named musselson
hanging along with him
we found that we had in fact deep common
interests I realized this is a guy who's
really very smart and I can learn a lot
from him I remember a haze of beach
parties
lectures that I slept through it was a
kind of paradise
the most interesting people in molecular
biology most of them were there so
that's how we met and then it turns out
Frank is coming that very September to
Caltech about a year from then I would
come are you sure yep oh I still hadn't
finished so I had to wait for a whole
year before I saw you again that's right
he said when you get to Caltech we'll
test Jim's idea what do you think about
testing Jim's idea of how DNA replicates
and then he explained that to me I'd
already heard about it he explained it
to me and I absolutely committed totally
and then when Frank finally got there
and I wanted to start right away he
forbade it
why he said it would be bad for my
character to not complete my x-ray
crystallography before starting
something new
this is tells you a lot about Frank's
character
with the Watson quick model the
underlying question of course was was
that really the right mechanism the
famous Max delbrook said no no no no
that model can't be right and he
proposed a different model as delbrook
put it forth breaks are introduced in
the parental molecule as it's being
replicated and then carefully sealed up
in certain ways others proposed one in
which the original DNA molecule stays
intact
and the new DNA molecule is made of all
new DNA
so there were three targets out there
that in principle could be distinguished
if you could trace the fate of the old
chains What Becomes of the two old
chains there's one step led to the next
really I mean the first idea using
density somehow
is not a very good idea yet except it
leads you to the next one Matt's idea
from the very beginning was that somehow
stable isotopes could be used that would
be incorporated into the DNA and impart
upon the DNA a different density you
grow bacteria in a medium which instead
of having this ordinary isotope of
nitrogen n14 you can buy nitrogen 15
ammonium chlorides a heavy kind
and if you grow the bacteria for a
number of generations you can be sure
that essentially all of the DNA
is labeled with the heavy nitrogens good
now we resuspend those cells in a medium
that just has ordinary not nitrogen 14
the light one
and now the question is is the DNA
molecules replicate how will the heavy
nitrogen from those parent molecules be
distributed amongst the daughter
molecules that are produced in
successive duplications then some
sensitive method for separating DNA
according to its density would be
devised I ran across an article about
the centrifugation of cesium chloride
solutions to measure their molecular
weight if the DNA was in there with the
cesium it would find its position in the
density gradient if it was Heavy DNA it
would tend to be down near the bottom of
the tube where the cesium was
concentrated and the density was high
if the DNA was light DNA made of light
Isotopes it would be higher up in the
tube
[Music]
think about it this way if you jump into
the Great Salt Lake as we all know you
float you go right to the top because
you are less dense than the water but if
you have a bathing suit with pockets in
it and you stuff some lead weights in
your pockets you'll sink down because
you're more dense than the water
now imagine that the salt in the Great
Salt Lake is not uniformly distributed
but is concentrated near the bottom
and rather less concentrated near the
top now if you put just the right number
of heavy weights in your pocket you
won't float because you'll be too dense
you won't float at the top and you won't
go all the way to the bottom because
you're not dense enough you'll instead
come to rest somewhere halfway between
the top and the bottom you will have
found your place in that gradient
and that's the very basis by which the
experiment finally worked and worked so
beautifully and then it was just a
question of looking in the centrifuge
while it's running and when it reaches
equilibrium
to see where the heavy and light DNA are
all the makings were there then to do
the experiment itself it was obvious
that the experiment was going to give an
answer driving it all was the fact that
Frank wanted to know how life works
[Music]
um
yeah
I'm not yeah
but I don't know there's not drove at
all but
each person is trying to come up with
something as a gift to the other guy
that's true I think that's true so it
becomes a very
connected relationship
because the next day you want to have
something to offer
melt was ready to step out into an area
full pretty heavily Uncharted to answer
an important question and the pieces had
to be built as he went along
[Music]
prediction of the Watson and Crick model
is the two parent chains come apart each
one makes a new daughter molecule and
that's replication so that would predict
that after exactly one generation when
everything has doubled in the bacterial
culture that you'd find the DNA
molecules all have one old strand which
is labeled heavy and one New Strand
which is labeled light and therefore
their density should be halfway between
fully heavy and fully light that would
be the prediction for what you see
at exactly one generation what do you
predict to see for the Next Generation
Well each molecule would again separate
its chains one of which is heavy the
other of which is light and the only
growth medium available is light growth
medium
then the light chain would make another
light chain to go with it a complement
the heavy chain would make another a
light chain to go with it so after two
generations you have DNA half of which
is half heavy and the other half of
which is all light
and fantastically that's exactly the
result that one could see
in order to say that the Watson Creek
model fits the data very well but the
other two models do not we have to see
what they predict
start with the dispersive model
after one generation the two molecules
resulting would indeed be half heavy but
in the next Generation there would be a
subsequent dispersion of the label so
you'd be getting molecules that were
three quarters light and one quarter
heavy and in each generation the
molecules would get lighter and lighter
the fully conservative model simply
imagined that duplex DNA fully heavy now
somehow created the appearance of a
fully light duplex molecule in which
both chains are made of light DNA
most of the times when you get an
experimental result
doesn't speak to you with such Clarity
these pictures of the DNA bands
interpreted themselves
[Music]
it felt like a
of course Supernatural it felt like you
were in touch with the gods or something
like that I remember I presented this
result that summer early in the summer
in France at a phage meeting
uh complete with the with the
photographs of the density gradient
bandings and at the end of it
a stop and there was total silence and
somebody said well that's it
the intellectual Freedom at Caltech we
could do whatever we wanted it was very
unusual for such young guys to do such
an important experiment so suddenly
whereas before that like Max would be
talking with sinsheimer about the
genetic code and before we did our
experiment I was definitely not at least
I felt I wasn't supposed to be at those
discussions but afterwards I could be a
full member
we had this wonderful house big house
across the street from the lab and our
roommates
we all we talked about these experiments
at almost every dinner
so we had this wonderful intellectual
atmosphere
uh John Drake Howard temen why are you
frowning you told the dirtiest jokes no
that was Roger Milkman
well okay you're right in positions one
and two that's true that's true that's
true so it was a very Lively intense
friendly atmosphere
it was Lively enough and conveniently
located enough that over time we had
visits from William O Douglas judge
Douglas judge Douglas of the Supreme
Court
here dick Feynman probably one of the
world's greatest physicists at that time
or maybe ever uh pal Duran with us he
came over to our big house and played
his drums down sat down on the floor
played their drums I'm just a graduate
student and he's the world's greatest
physicist but that's what it was like it
was a very friendly wide open place
Frank and I are very lucky
the way I think of it is that there's a
river which is a period of time when the
fundamental things the structure of DNA
how replication happens the genetic code
and then it when these solve these
problems are solved there are lots of
little rivulets the river divides into
thousands of branches using these
fundamental insights into how life works
and applying them to specific questions
questions of disease etc etc
so to me with some exceptions
this was a really interesting time when
it was still a big river
also now that you can cut this out but
also the meselson's Matt's parents were
kind enough to keep the liquor cabinet
fully stocked at all times
[Music]
foreign
is a little bit
the cough drops suffering
no no no
no I require a margarita I've worked for
the CIA for the giant squids and all
that I vaporized many people including
many of your friends a big black beard
and blew out some of his bike smooth and
still holding his pipes down in his
decent old man
history is just what people think it was
oh